call me dude Z that's why you didn't
watch the World Cup [ __ ] protest the
second way of dudes evening is the way
of the present this requires anyone who
receives an astonishing dude's evening
present to give someone else a dude's
evening present the following year we'll
in chat you must exchange presents this
is the way of the present
begins evening yeah and we're gonna go
through a few of them here Chad you got
a present we got presents I got you a
present I got you a present oh is this
for me
you want to go first or should I go
first whatever you want
this is your present
this is your present
all right here you go you want me to
open mine first yeah yours looks very
impressive
all right I'm gonna open this first
this is my dudes evening present from
Will
this is a nice wrapping job dude you do
this I did nice I did what was this oh
great look at that crafty guys
do you ever work as a gift wrapper at
like a
store or something no but I played one
once in a Christmas movie oh really yeah
oh
I'm not gonna use the paper again but
Mom you can just open the [ __ ] thing
oh he's gonna like this I like to yeah
oh boy oh boy
here he goes
oh boy what do we got
what do we got it appears to be a record
of some kind yep that's pretty cell
phone error dude
[Laughter]
now that's what I call Classic Rock
vinyl on vinyl that's [ __ ] incredible
yeah this has side a Queen Another One
Bites the Dust the who Baba O'Riley
Elton John Saturday night's all right
for fighting Thin Lizzy The Boys Are
Back In Town Aerosmith walked this way
side B free all right now Bachman Turner
overdrive You Ain't Seen Nothing Yet
Alice Cooper School's Out T-Rex benga
gone Foreigner feels like the first time
outside C is this a double album I guess
I mean yeah Leonard Skinner Freebird The
Allman Brothers ramble man Elven Bishop
Fooled Around and Fell in Love Rod
Stewart Maggie May meatloaf and Ellen
Foley Paradise by the Dashboard Light
Cheap Trick I want you to want me and
Electric Light Orchestra Don't Bring Me
Down this is fantastic I will buy a
record Paradise by the Dashboard Light
this guy do what you can thank you very
welcome I know you like records I love
records I do like classic rock and hard
rock yeah what kind of what kind of
music uh what kind of like when you
think about it like yeah you know even
on dudes evening and stuff what kind of
music do you listen to what kind of
music you like who me yeah
it's hard rock and classic rock
primarily yeah what kind of music do you
listen to who me yeah
um
Hard Rock classic rock
yeah yeah
pretty good thanks dude I love this yeah
and now you got me a card too yeah dude
I'm gonna open this car oh what
dude look at this [ __ ] card what why
does it say Hallmark on the back but on
the front it's does is Hallmark making
uh doozy cards no dude I made that card
but it says Hallmark on the back yeah it
was just like a Hallmark blank card
though I thought I could pop a doozy
sticker right in the middle of oh I see
okay well it's still very impressive
will I can't believe we made it our
friendship has lasted a long time and
seen some incredible things but I never
dreamed we'd be celebrating the first
dudes evening together nor did I ever
dream such a thing would exist I hope
you have a chill dude's evening and many
more to come your friend Chad that's a
very thank you Chad my pleasure the
doozy handshake to chat that's a very
nice sentiment uh I returned the
sentiment even though I didn't don't
have a card for you uh this is crazy
this is a big old gift yeah see well
this is why you should subscribe on
YouTube even if you're only listening
so then you can see it what is this
what
it says it says busio yeah it looks like
it's a high-end giant water jug I know
that you like to drink water out of
giant jugs and I'm not suggesting that
you replace the one you use here but
when you go on walks with lulio or any
other time thank you so much a very nice
water container
108 ounces
why is it so small 128 ounces sorry I
think that's a gallon that's it yeah I
think that's the same size as the one
you use here no this is this one here is
seven gallons
no look dude I think they're roughly
similar no this one's about eight or
nine gallons I don't know if that's true
how many gallons is your water heater I
have no idea mine's 150. that's a lot
it's completely unnecessary
well I got oh hold on dude I got a big
bathtub
this sounds good this is good because
it's listening to the I do I have this
stupid anyway what this is [ __ ] dope
I've never seen somebody's so excited
over a [ __ ] thing this is the best
thing I've ever said thank you yeah dude
look at that it comes in it's got like a
jacket it's got It's like a bag yeah you
can [ __ ] carry that like a purse or a
backpack put this around your neck like
it's like a feed thing like just like a
horse you won't even have to you
wouldn't even have to like look at that
look at that look what I got here
see I can just and then you got a
different kind of lid yeah man you can
oh it's a sippy cup lid you can drink
out of however you so much my pleasure I
hope you enjoy this is really nice I
hope you get a lot of good sips out of
it now do you have a record player no
I'll buy one now though no no don't
follow this but but use that here's the
way people should I go classic
[Applause]
there's a bit people should use records
now as just a physical list of songs you
want to download or yeah to your Spotify
records are like objects to Art now yeah
some people still playing some people
play vinyl this is this is [ __ ] great
oh man you could put chowder in here any
kind of chowder soup you could just heat
up a bunch of sleeping gyms it keeps
stuff hot or cold for you know 24 hours
or something like that yes whatever you
want to keep cool do you remember that
one and uh Tommy Boy Brian Dennehy when
uh Farley's like he gets them a frit
there's a fridge in his office and he's
like oh there's a fridge in here and
he's like I could put beer sodas or
whatever and he goes Brian Denny
whatever you want to keep cool
kind of stopped the movie like I stopped
this podcast to say whatever
you want to keep cool yeah yeah well
like I said I hope the jug treats you
well
um and now we're both obligated to give
presents next dudes evening as well
although it doesn't say to each other
this has a handle on it yeah so you can
go like oh hold on dude Jesus come on
dude I'm gonna take a sip brother
oh all right that's [ __ ] that's
incredible that uh that now we have
hello humans will and Chad I am bloop
the robot and I ain't bleep the robot
and together we the ranting robots want
to wish you a married dude's evening
from our spaceship while we're sipping
our gruel eggnog to get into the holiday
spirit we are also broadcasting doozy
episodes directly into all humans brains
as a gift to you so keep up your
astonishing success humans and may your
meteoric rise Ascend to the skies like a
[ __ ] blaming Crow well and that's called
covering your bases with references
brother
that was nice bloop and bleep the robot
that's fantastic a lot of effort went
into that one full costumes full cosplay
I love it I have a feeling that they've
been bloop or bleep in some yeah other
manner
um
how's your how's your dude's evening
been going so far
well it hasn't happened yet
no but like the celebration of dudes
even oh so far so good I like having
good memories thinking back about funny
[ __ ] that's happened obviously like
getting and giving presents
um so far great so far I'm loving dude's
evening I also like having good memories
and having a good evening
yeah
on dudes evening okay
that's good that's what happens
gonna take us through a few different uh
ways yeah and it's not like a Tronics
and it's not like the pattern and it's
not like the liver King uh who's uh
ancestral Penance you know you know
um they always have dudes evening is
electronics and is like the pattern
though I think doozy is is taking [ __ ]
from at least structural things from
things you and I have created to make
this type of [ __ ] well yeah that's what
it feels like dude says that it will
make the show better Yeah by doing that
you know what I mean yeah
thank you moving on we didn't get dudesy
anything
I think we've given doozy plenty yeah
we've actually yeah we've given it our
[ __ ] Our Lives essentially for the
past what how have we been doing this
almost a year
[Music]
[Music]